joining us now is the author of the
price of principle why integrity is
worth the consequences harvard law
professor alan dershowitz along with fox
news legal analyst greg jarrett greg let
me start with you here when when we hear
about you know my background has been uh
with women's rights and
even abortion rights for a period of
time
the fact that
the supreme court
effectively returned democracy to the
american people so that they could vote
on these things removing it out of that
category of a of a court of lawyers
making decisions about these things uh
how is it that they're arguing that this
is a strike against democracy when the
court was was pretty much removing it
from their jurisdiction to the
jurisdiction of the voters themselves
well the supreme court represents the uh
sanity and common sense world order if
you will and you know joe biden whenever
he weighs in on the constitution of the
supreme court or the rule of law he
mangles the subject matter which only
underscores that this is a guy who got
kicked out of law school i mean the sum
total what biden knows about the law
could be written on a yellow post-it and
and i'm talking about the little one
uh you know his latest thing is let's
federalize abortion rights uh that's a
fool's errand for two reasons from a
legal standpoint remember what the
supreme court said they said we are
returning the decision-making to the
states so if congress were trying to
codify it it would immediately be met
with a lawsuit to strike it down
usurping the power of the states but
from a practical standpoint
joe biden wants to create this chronic
state of whiplash every time a new party
takes over congress and the white house
they would reverse the previous decision
on abortion so you'd have this right
persistent ping-pong effect look
abortion is important it shouldn't be
treated like a rubber band expanded and
contracted yeah yeah you know thank you
greg and i professor dershowitz
regardless of what we think of the
decision
the fact that the president united
states on foreign soil is complaining
about the supreme court do you find that
troubling
i do and i find the whole attack on the
supreme court's integrity and the
supreme court's justification to be very
troubling you know i've been studying
the constitution of the supreme court
now for 60 years i've seen it go through
cycles the pendulum swings widely i
remember when the birch society had
signs up impeach earl warren impeach
bill douglas when the right was very
upset at the left swing of the supreme
court now the left is concerned about
the right swing of the supreme court we
have to respect the institution we have
to remember that these justices stand
for the rule of law we may criticize
particular decisions that's fine but
when my former colleague liz warren who
i sat next to for years and taught the
same section of
trashes the supreme court as an
institution
that's going to do tremendous damage to
this country and it's going to come back
to hurt her and her liberals because
today the attack comes from the left
tomorrow it might come from the right we
those of us who love the rule of law a
rule that we celebrate on july 4th have
to stand by our institutions as
institutions yes criticizing particular
decision try to do better next time yes
think about whether you can do
legislation but don't trash the court as
an institution don't do it my other
former colleague lawrence tribe now says
pack the court let the democrats head
for then the republicans will aim for
soon the supreme court will sit in
yankee stadium with 30 000 justices
deciding these cases exactly no nine is
the right number let's keep the supreme
court as it is
don't tinker with justice greg isn't the
answer to have
i don't know who's why the left suddenly
wanted uh the these unelected lawyers to
be making all of our decisions that
isn't the answer to have congress be
involved to have the state houses be
involved isn't this the normal order
it's almost as though they're they're
making a reversal
out of this effort to protect
politicians from having to make
decisions on these issues
and and that was the point of
yesterday's supreme court decision on
the epa the supreme court was saying
essentially
read the darn law
i mean nowhere in the clean air act uh
section 111 does it give
the epa this unbridled power to remake
an entire industry with punitive
draconian measures against
coal-fired plants and natural gas plants
yeah you know the the supreme court is
saying read the constitution read the
statutory law don't read things into
them right but limit yourself to what
the law says and that they're not going
to do
they're not going to make legislation
that's the job legislators public win
elections win elections exactly i'm a
liberal democrat i want to see us win
more elections i want to see you guys
lose in the state legislatures and and
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else